Thank you.
All right.
Good morning, everyone.
It is nine o'clock.
We're going to open up the committee of conference on House Bill 1547.
And we have present myself, Howard Pearl, the chair, ranking member, Rep Bixby, vice chair, Judy Aaron from finance, Tracy Embrick and two senators.
Yeah, my head just went blank.
Senator Waters and him.
Senator Daniels, thank you.
Sorry, I don't know where my head went.
And Senator Bradley is not going to be in attendance.
So in review of House Bill 1547, the House had asked for a committee of conference because there was a $25 million appropriation that was added to the original bill.
And the House Finance Committee had wanted an opportunity to take a look at that and make sure that they felt the funding was there and appropriate.
And in speaking with Chairman Umberger yesterday, she informed me that she is okay and is comfortable with the bill.
So I think unless there's other objections from anyone on the committee, the House will agree to accede to the changes that is in the Senate amendment on House Bill 1547.
Anybody else want to weigh in?
Yeah, I'm happy that we can come to this position of acceding.
I think it makes sense to put the money towards the fund.
And in reviewing the bill, I did detect one typographical error.
There is a reference to Section 2, which should be Section 2A.
And I talked to OLS, and they said that that could be resolved in the bill process rather than having to do an amendment.
Any further comment from anyone?
Thank you.
and they said that that could be resolved in the enrolled bill process rather than having to do an amendment.
Any further comment from anyone?
Representative of Emory?
Yeah, the prime sponsor is here.
I spoke with her, and she's quite pleased with the Senate Amendment.
Great.
Well, I know there's been a lot of work on the bill, and we thank you for all your work you've done on it, Representative Mooney.
It definitely was a good bill in the end.
We made a lot of changes to it.
Anything else?
I think we may get this to be one of the shortest committee conferences of the week.
All right.
Well, with that, then, we're all in agreement.
Do we need to pick a formal vote?
We do not.
And we'll, as far as I can then, we're all in agreement.
Do we need to take a formal vote?
We do not.
And we'll, as far as I can tell, we're all in agreement on this.
And we'll sign off once it's ready from OLS.
Great.
We can do the sign off by calling in.
We can.
Yep, sign off coming down by calling.
That is correct.
Well, we thank you all.
And with that, we're going to close the committee conference on House Bill 1547.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay, I'd like to go ahead and start.
It's continuing our discussion on 1661.
And I'm going to open this up by asking Representative Turcotte to please go ahead and explain the amendment which he has.
okay i have not seen the amendment delivered here yet i just finished receiving it so i'm assuming it's going to be brought up here shortly.
They said they were going to bring it up.
So I'm waiting on 400.
We're waiting for that to arrive.
Okay.
So let's start out by discussing, walking through the entire bill that we've done so everybody understands where we are and what we have to do.
Sure.
Representative Chircotte, would you please do that?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Okay.
So we know there's several pieces in this.
We'll start off by saying that we know HB 1476 was removed.
That's going to its own committee of conference or has gone SB 420.
That was also removed and that is also in a committee of conference at this time.
We know there's a.
The first first part of it, the career technical education that we don't have any apparent disagreements on the next section was the legislative garage which originally had a $35 million from the house.
The Senate's version has it at $9.35 million.
We know that the speaker is more than happy with that.
We do not require any additional money.
Matter of fact, I believe that's probably a more fiscally responsible start.
that leaves us with two other pieces 430 and 400 again i'm waiting for 400 to come sb 430 i mentioned this several times at the hearing last week that uh that was um came over after we had an amendment 1440 placed on it.
The Senate declined to hear that and they non-concurred.
And then they took their version of 430 and placed that onto HB 1661.
As far as we're concerned, that portion, SB 430, is no longer on the table.
SB 400, while we're still waiting for the amendment to get here, I will say, I think we can still talk about it because last week we went through a listing of issues we said were okay, some that were not.
And we had that turned into the amendment that's going to be forthcoming.
Now, I understand there's three issues that possibly remain, and I will get those out.
Start with 92 and 93.
And again, I'm going to assume all the rest of the amendment once it gets here that the Senate has agreed to.
I believe it's 83, 92, and 93 that there's some issues with.
I want to start with 92 and 93 and speak to why we are against those being in the bills.
If you look at them, I'd like to read, especially from 93, the piece that's being added says, acquire, construct, reconstruct, improve, alter, extend, operate, maintain, or promote residential developments.
Now, the problem that we have with that is cities and municipalities and towns becoming landlords.
We have received, or I know I have received a lot of pushback from individuals on this in our caucus.
And the reason it's so bad, I guess the easiest way to describe it is if you go and you look at the RSA that talks about municipal economic development and revitalization districts, Thank you.
way to describe it is if you go and you look at the RSA that talks about municipal economic development and revitalization districts, before those districts can be put into law or into a municipality, that has to go before either the voters or the elected officials of that municipality.
This here, by adding what I just read to you in there, that is going to bypass the voters and the elected officials if those towns or municipalities already have these revitalization districts within their town.
So what I would suggest is I don't think in the long run, I know I wouldn't be against this.
However, for those sections that we're adding, if we were to add them, and we couldn't do it now, but I think we must insist that the voters of those communities or the elected officials, I prefer the voters, they should have the ability to decide if they're going to add this extra section of acquire, construct, reconstruct, improve, alter, extend, operate, maintain, promote residential developments in their districts.
Again, these are the areas, those two sections, 92 and 93, that we have issues with for those reasons.
Now, 80, let me see if I can find it, 83.
That one is similar, and actually this is the one we had the most pushback from our caucus on, and that was basically calling workforce housing for older persons, or having the ability of older person communities to be considered workforce housing.
Again, that's an issue we think should be approved by voters or the elected officials in town.
And putting this into SB 400, we don't believe should be there.
I think all the rest the Senate has agreed to.
I think that's pretty much it.
Thank you.
Senator Bradley, do you have any, we just brought up that as a discussion item.
Any input here?
So I think that we could agree to drop sections 86, 89, 90, and 94.
We want to retain 83, 92, and 93.
And maybe, is Ben Frost in the room?
Is there somebody from the housing community, Alyssa, that could answer a question?
Sure.
Are they in the room?
Okay.
Welcome.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for the record.
I'm Alyssa Margolin.
I serve as Director of Housing Action New Hampshire.
So my question would be, you heard the concern raised by Representative Turcotte.
If in section 82, 92, and 93, we said something to the effect of subject to a vote of the governing body, which in the case of a town would be the voters, in the case of cities would be the city council, and then the authorization in those three sections would go through.
Is that workable?
Thank you, Senator, for the question.
I think for the TIF financing 92-93 or 93, 94, that would work if the governing bodies had a say, because it's only enabling anyway.
I'm not sure it works for the density proposal, which basically says that if a community has already decided so if that governing body has already made a decision to provide incentives and density for one population they can't exclude another Mr.
Chair?
Yes.
Can I ask Representative Turcotte a question?
Well, if he's willing to take the question.
Mr.
Chair?
Yes.
Can I ask Representative Turcotte a question?
Well, if he's willing to take the question.
Of course he is.
I will do my best.
This is all.
This particular issue is new to me, but I'll do my best, Senator.
Yeah, well.
um so if we were to go with your suggestion on 92 and 93, subject to a vote of the governing body, and on 83, if we were to add, I'd have to think about this, because I think Ms.
Margolin is correct.
the way the language is written.
It's a new paragraph, but a municipality would have already allowed housing for the elderly with the incentives.
What this does is say if you do for one, you do for workforce.
I hate to think out loud.
It's always dangerous.
But maybe you and I can have a discussion about how to word something like that so that there would be approval somehow of the voters of...
of what I don't want to see happen, I guess, is for communities that have already approved elderly housing, that we require new approval for the elderly housing that's already been approved by approving something for workforce.
Do you see what I'm saying, Representative Turcotte?
I believe I do.
I would not be opposed to working on that.
I won't speak for the entire House caucus, but I believe if we could develop something along those lines, that that be a possibility i'm looking at 162k i was frantically trying to find it um and again for the those municipalities who have already put 162k into their um onto their books our major concern was having this thrust upon them without a vote.
And 162K1 speaks very clearly on that.
I'm actually into the RSAs.
I know, but it says amend RSA 674.
Go down to 93.
No, we're on 83.
Well, he mentioned the couple of them.
I'm speaking to 93, basically.
See, I think we can do 93 and 94 easily.
That's what I'm saying.
And if we can do 93 and 94 using what's laid out in the way of a majority vote of the voters, I'm particularly concerned about the voters, not so much the legislative body.
But I'm guessing if there's a way to make that work, there's probably a way to make the other work.
The concern would be if we undermine communities that already have elderly housing.
And I'm looking, is there a representative of the municipal association in the room i think yeah while they're coming up uh jeb uh on the the bill itself where we're looking at this roman four uh the section that we're talking about 83 if, if we change shall to may in there, would that make a difference?
May subject to approval of so-and-so?
This is why I wanted somebody from the Municipal Association.
Do you have a copy of the bill?
I do not in front of me, sir.
Here, she can look at mine for right now.
Okay.
Somebody's's gonna help you this is as you sorry i was looking at it electronically all right so we are on page 20 bottom of page 25.
So the issue is communities have already approved, presumably, elderly housing.
How do we, without undermining that, have an approval process for workforce housing?
If you could give me some time, I can get you some language in an hour or so, sir.
I like that answer, Representative Turcotte.
What do you think?
Should we wait and see?
I think that's the smart thing.
You mentioned it before.
I think there's nothing worse than operating on the fly, so I would be more than happy to do that.
Thank you.
Okay.
Thank you very much, Catherine.
That may help us.
Okay.
And, Mr.
Chairman, I could suggest while she's drafting something to look at sections 92 and 93 because representative turcotte's concern needs to be replicated there also and i think in in those sections the uh the 162 k1 that talks about local option i think that's's what I'd like to see in there would be the second part of that where it talks about a town may adopt this chat, thereby a majority vote of the voters.
That makes sense.
To me, we just don't want to throw this into these communities that already have it and just say, oh, guess what?
I think this is very reasonable, Representative.
Representative Turk, Representative Hamburger?
Well, I was looking down the...
Go ahead, Representative Hamburger.
You're late on.
Yeah, the only question I have is that we can't save voters in the cities that have city councils.
So we'll have to allow the city councils to make that.
Elected officials.
Yeah.
But I don't, you know, I think we need to.
This is why I wanted the Municipal Association to look at it.
I think the way it normally works is subject to the governing body, which in a city would be the city council.
And in towns, it would be.
The voters.
Yes, down there.
Representative Cardelli.
Thank you.
Just one other thing, looking at the language related to Section 83, the one area where I would have a concern is the last part of the last sentence which indicates regardless of a local land use ordinance or regulation.
So it looks to me like with that phrase, we are overruling local control of their own ordinances.
That would be my concern in terms of drafting any new language related to section 83 we could just take that out mr chair yes i i actually think he's correct so my suggestion would be since this was very important to new hampshire housing finance authority and housing advocates.
Let's see what the attorney for the municipal association comes back with, and hopefully it's workable.
Okay?
You might consider a period right after on line six, after development, period.
And I think you're probably correct with that.
Okay.
Okay, so now we've, hopefully we've addressed several of those concerns with this bill, this portion of it.
Are there any other areas within Representative Turcotte that we should be looking at?
On the amendment?
On the amendment, that's right.
No, last week in the amendment, or last meeting, committee conference meeting, I went through and went through all the different issues where we believed it should stay in or come out, and I didn't have any other input as to things that the Senate did not disagree on.
Okay, I was just handed the amendment.
Right.
Would you please walk us through that?
I would say at this point, because of 92 and 93, there's going to be a further amendment, so it would probably almost be not worth our time.
It's not worth our time right now.
You made some changes to 85, correct?
Unfortunately, the numbers aren't going to line up like they used to.
Yeah, it's the numbers.
It dropped to 83.
I got you.
The body of the bill is what we just, we as the House talked about on, was it Friday?
But again, that's going to change now if we come up with new language on those three sections.
So we have just been talking about the SB 400 section.
Are there any other portions of this which we want to look at?
We know we're going to have to come back to see the modified language here that we just discussed.
Are there any other portions of the entire bill that we want to discuss at this time or need to hammer on?
I think you need to talk about 430.
That's the recommendation.
Okay.
430 then.
Are there any any you know you heard the the discussion presented at the very beginning by the house uh does the senate have any reaction to that so i think we indicated last week and obviously we want to see an amendment that we were okay with all of the changes agreed to by the house health and human services committee and house finance we were not okay with the adding of 1044 but i think based on what um representative turcott Let's see.
finance, we were not okay with the adding of 1044, but I think based on what Representative Turcotte said, that's not part of the discussion.
So we're happy about that.
So I believe- Let me clarify, Senator.
The House position is what the House came out on 430, including 1044, not excluding.
That's why we, in my opening, I stated that 430, as we see it, is not in play anymore.
The Senate was given the opportunity.
The Senate gave us a non-concur on it and then took the amendment off and put, uh, 430 back onto this.
So 430 is not, not on the table.
I'm not sure I'm following.
in our last house session the hb4 the SB 430 that came out of the House was our version and a floor amendment that Representative Edwards added was floor amendment 1044S.
That is the current House position position i don't know if i can say it another way so and i'll also add senator before um we were told by the uh clerk that we cannot use that position in this bill.
So unfortunately, because the Senate did a non-concur when it was a standalone, we cannot talk about our last House position and that was what included 1044.
All right.
So I think I understand that we're House Bill 1044 that the Senate non-concurred with is off the table at this point.
we cannot discuss it because the clerk said we cannot include it.
However, the last House position was SB 430, and it included the Edwards floor amendment.
And since the Senate non-concurred, the current, our position now is 430 is no longer uh sp430 is no longer in play can i get a clarification um maybe it's from the house clerk i don't understand why 430 would be out of play if we non-concurred with a non-germain amendment to it?
The House position is SB 430 with 1044 attached.
Without 1044 being attached, we are not willing to accede to only the House's previous position of 430.
Thank you.
We are not willing to accede to only the House's previous position of 430.
I've got Paul right here.
Paul, you're on speakerphone right now.
Mr.
Chairman, I'm not sure I understand Representative Turcotte's statement of 430 is not in play.
430 was added in 1661 at the Senate.
So the discussion regarding 430 can certainly take place.
The amendment, Representative Edwards' amendment that was added, that was not agreed to by Senate, which was not germane to this particular Bill 1661.
But 430 in and of itself can certainly be considered.
Paul, what you're saying is, is because the amendment was non-germaine and was killed by the Senate, that it cannot be brought up in the Committee of Conference.
Is that what you're saying?
Yes, I appreciate it.
It's not in your discussion at all.
but the rest discussing that at all.
We knew that.
Do you want to sit here?
No, we understand, Paul.
We understand where we're at.
When I said 430 is off the table, it wasn't in that sense that you're talking about.
Are there any other questions of the House Clerk?
Thank you, Paul.
Hold on.
Just make sure that he answered Aaron's question.
It did?
Thank you.
Yes, Senator.
So then based on that conversation, I just want to make sure that the contents of house bill 1044 which were added by you folks as a floor amendment that we non-concurred with when i say it's off the table for discussions you're not trying to bring that back at this point is that my understanding Thank you.
concurred with when I say it's off the table for discussions, you're not trying to bring that back at this point.
Is that my understanding?
We cannot bring that back.
And therefore, the entire rest of the rest of let me make let me figure this.
I'll show you be a little different on how I tell you this.
Starting on page six of the side-by-side and going to whenever all those items within 430 were to the end of that.
Page 37.
So what we're saying, since the Senate non-concurred on our version with 1044 attached, that pages 6 through, would you say, Karen, 37, are no longer part of our...
It's 35.
Am I saying that right?
35.
So when I say SB 430 is off the table, it means we're not interested in discussing any part of that.
I'm not sure that that's what your clerk said.
Maybe I misunderstood him, but I'm not sure that that's what he said.
I think we're looking at maybe semantics here.
Forget about the actual pieces of 430, if you will.
Think about the process.
The process was we had 430 and 1044.
We could have gone to a committee of conference on that.
The Senate decided they did not want to and non-concurred.
Now 430 has been brought back into here.
On the side-by-side, they have our last position, less 1044.
What we are saying is all those positions that are in there, because 1044 that the Senate non-concurred, we are no longer willing to entertain those.
I don't know how many more ways I can say it.
I don't know if I'm, am I not being clear?
Is the word willing the word to use or able?
Willing.
Willing?
Allowed?
Correct.
According to Paul Smith, we are able.
But the question is, are we willing?
Yeah.
And the answer on that, no.
well I think if we're going to discuss 1044 we should discuss 1044 because um my understanding of 1044 is that the structure of it definitely undermines critical access hospitals that some of us at this committee of conference represent.
I have two in my district.
I think Senator Hennessy has four.
I think Representative Cordelli has one.
Representative Umberger has one.
And I'm not sure about you, Representative, but we heard extensive testimony in the senate hhs committee that it was more than problematic for um the critical access hospitals and the critical access hospitals are a vital healthcare delivery system for much of the rural areas of the state, the western areas of the state and the northern areas of the state.
So that's why the Senate rejected that.
And I'm not signing a committee of conference report that 1044 comes back.
Sorry, Terry.
Representative Berger.
Thank you.
Senator Bradley, I think that what Paul was saying is that we could not bring 1044 back.
We could not.
Right, but then the rest of 430, what Representative Turcotte is saying, is also out.
And I didn't hear him say that.
Yes, that's what he said.
That's correct.
All the items contained in 430 can be brought back in six to eight months if they're there.
There's still a lot of items in there that many had problems with to begin with, but those can be 430 can be brought back.
So we're hung up on where we are here.
I would say the first thing is we get the language on SB 400 and see if we can come to some kind of an agreement on that.
I don't actually see that as a problem.
Go from there.
I think you guys should talk to him offline.
Paul?
No, you're on with me.
I think perhaps we're going to have to take a little time and talk with you on the side.
I understand the rest of the bill is fine.
We can talk about, you know, 430.
I understand that.
We're not talking.
What about that amendment, though?
That's no, right?
Yes.
That's the rest of the bill.
Go ahead.
Thank you.
Clerk's gonna come over here and be here in about a minute.
Okay.
We have a two-minute break.
It's cooler in that building.
We're going to take a break.
I know it's really hot out there.
And we'll come back as soon as Paul Smith gets here.
Thank you.
Those that are in attendance right now, what I'm going to do is we're going to ask that we hear from Paul for a second.
Just ask Paul one question, and then after that, we're going to adjourn.
No, you're not.
You're going to recess.
Recess for a date, a time to be determined determined.
My question is that it's my understanding, and you could just say yes or no, that the decision to address 430 is our decision here, that we can address 430, but we cannot address the amendment that we're talking about, the Edwards Amendment.
Is that correct?
Yes, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you.
So with that, we're going to recess this to a time to be determined.
It's going to be at least 24 hours from now.
12.
12, excuse me, 12.
We've started.
Well, I ain't not coming back 12 hours from now.
So we will, what's a good time for?
I suggest my name.
Well, I ain't not coming back 12 hours from now.
So we will, what's the time for?
I'd suggest 9 a.m.
on Wednesday.
9 a.m.
I would suggest 9 a.m.
on Wednesday.
Well, we don't all have to be here I believe 9 a.m.
would be good for us Too early in the morning?
Yes I understand coming from Conway, but...
Okay.
9 o'clock on Wednesday morning, we will meet here.
9.30 is good, too.
Is that better?
9.30 Wednesday.
And that's getting us pretty close to the deadline to have this job done.
Thursday.
So this meeting is recessed.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Is the NHMA, are they going to get that language to you?
Or do you also have it?
Yeah, I'll get it to you.
Okay.
Yep.
I don't know where to have to go on this.
Thank you.